hey this is very interesting we've been
thinking out loud what is going to be
the landing spot for lots of former
trump administration officials and one
of the
former administration officials that as
the trump administration was winding
down i
said this person deserves this person
should be unhireable for the degree of
dishonesty
and humiliation that they participated
in uh during the trump administration i
was talking about
one of donald trump's former press
secretary is kaylee mcinanny and
we sort of said maybe she'll do some
kind of communication or consulting for
some right-wing group maybe she'll
become a pundit or go back to being a
pundit or something like that
crew the citizens for ethics watch
citizens for ethics i forget what the w
stands for citizens for ethics
i think watch they found a
uh they found in kaylee mcinanny's
financial disclosures
um an indication that kaylee had a gig
lined up with fox news and of course
that would not be in any way surprising
to us
there is a sort of revolving door in
fact between
fox news and the trump administration
trump often even thinking of hiring
people
after seeing them on fox news this
document
was exposed and it was revealed that
kaylee mcinanni reached an agreement
with fox news
to start working there this month
however after this was revealed
um there was a statement put out by fox
news
saying simply kaylee mcinanni is not
currently an employee or contributor at
fox news
what may have happened here and at this
point it is mere speculation
is that while the agreement was in place
early in january for kaylee to start at
fox news
the january 6th riots and just the
disaster that ended up being the final
days of the trump administration
made fox rethink at least temporarily
this
deal and while i think it is completely
plausible that in a month in two months
and six months who knows kaylee mcinanni
is going to show up as a contributor on
fox news it seems maybe they have just
paused it and they're deciding to delay
this
and if you look at the very carefully
worded statement from fox news again
their only statement was kaylee mcinanni
is not currently an employee
or contributor at fox news it seems as
though they are choosing to delay that
now there were also
other really interesting things in
kaylee mcinanny's financial disclosure
one is that the on-campus right-wing
group
turning point usa which is
charlie kirk is the guy who's known to
be the sort of
public-facing figure of that
organization turning point usa
paid for a 6500
gift for kaylee and a guest to go to
an event in which she received an award
okay in december kaylee went to the
winter gala
at mar-a-lago and there were obviously
questions about
what there's a there's a pandemic what
the hell are they doing
she was given an award by turning point
usa
at trump's mar-a-lago and she was given
a 6 500
gift she also reported receiving
close to two hundred thousand dollars in
salary and bonus
from the trump campaign and rnc
um and that includes a few months before
she started working at the white house
but it is reported that she was still
getting paid
twelve thousand dollars or more
by the campaign after working at the
white house campaign employee
government employee same time while
getting gifts from turning point usa
and making deals with fox news while uh
still the press secretary of the united
states
it's wacky stuff i don't think any of us
will find this to be
even remotely surprising if we were
wondering about
the trajectory on fox news for the next
couple of years
hiring one of the biggest trump liars
and sycophants
hints to me that they're not planning on
getting away from the trumpy stuff they
in fact they may fox news may have to go
more pro-trump
in order to compete with oan and newsmax
remember that in the aftermath
of trump not being able to steal the
election from joe biden
many fox news viewers abandoned fox news
and went over to oan
and or newsmax and this is a a real
issue for fox news if they
believe that they need to go more trumpy
to maintain or regain their audience
where do the traditional conservatives
go not that i care
but i am certainly curious about that
and if republicans learn nothing from
trump
and move further in the trumpian
direction
do the traditional republicans become
centrist democrats i i'm genuinely
unsure
i don't feel bad for them the
traditional republicans starting with
ronald reagan in the 1980s
going to newt gingrich in the 1990s they
benefited from the same
anti-intellectualism uh that led
to trump so i don't feel bad for them at
all it's merely a curiosity
where do they go if fox news goes full
trump um
for now kaylee mcinanny will not be
joining fox news
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now because of how powerful it
is it only takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like
shelves and curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head
the shower head starts at just 199 but
the first hundred people who go to
nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get
15 percent off all nebia products the
link is underneath this video